[Müzik]
Urfa Siverek doğumluyum 8 çocuklu bir
aileden geliyorum 7 çocuğuyum
münteha isminin anlamı bana çok
soruluyor ekranda da gördüğünüz gibi 6
kız olunca
toprağın ve erkeğin gücün çok yoğun
olduğu bir bölgede de yaşıyorsanız
Sevgili anneciğimin yapması gereken
ikinci erkek çocuğu da dünyaya
getirmeseydi
benim bölgemde adını koyduğunuz zaman
arkasından gelen mutlaka erkek oluyormuş
geç konuşmuş bir isim ama Kader diyoruz
Benim de dünyaya gelirim varmış
şimdi tabi
Urfa Siverek 8 çocukla aile dediğin de
herkes bir trajedi bekliyor işte arkada
Müslüm Gürses kulaklarda koyunlar
geçiyor velilerek müthiş bir trajedi Ben
trajedinin sadece karın açlığı olduğunu
düşünmüyorum ruh açlığı Aslında size
harekete geçiriyor şimdi Siverek'te
yaşarken avlulu ev gökyüzünü o avlulu
evin
çerçevelediği duvarların üzerinden
görüyorsunuz müthiş bir özgürlük
çocuksunuz sokaklarda oynuyorsunuz kız
erkek ayrımını bilmiyorsunuz
ötekileştirmeyi hiç bilmiyorsunuz ta ki
televizyon gelip
Şu anda da dijitalin geldiği gibi
doğamızı bozana kadar
her şey çok normal ve akışındaydı sonra
yılbaşında televizyonlarda dansöz de
tanıştık sonra Dallas girdi hayatımıza
entrik kanı çeşitlerini gördük Aslında
dünyanın Bulunduğunuz noktada ibaret
olmadığını anlamaya başlıyorsunuz
başladığınız anda da sorgular devreye
giriyor
İstanbul'a gelmeden önce
ortaokul ilkokul bitti ortaokula
başladığımda bulunduğum bölgede hiç
Savaş başladı 79-80 Türkiye olaylarını
bilmeyen yok işte 11-12 yaşlarındayım
doğal olarak çok iyi bir eğitim alamadım
İstanbul'a Benim sıram gelmişti Erenköy
sitesine ablamdan sonra benim kaydım
yapıldı kaydım yapıldı geldim
attan inip eşeğe binmenin de demek
olduğunu gördüm
gerçekten orada bir şeyken İstanbul'a
geliyorsunuz hiçbir şeysiniz hiçbir
kimliğiniz yok Sadece size yapıştırılan
kimliklerle yol almaya çalışıyorsunuz ve
o kimlikleri temizlemek için de müthiş
mücadele veriyorsunuz Çünkü siz
Güneydoğu'dan çıktığınızda zaten
etiketlerinizi cebinize koyarak
geliyorsunuz Siz cebinizde koymuyorsunuz
size yapıştırıyorlar Yani bizden çıkan
teröristtir bizden çıkan kırodur bizden
çıkan yol yordam bilmeyendir İstanbul da
geldiğimde şunu gördüm benim
çocukluğumda yaşadığım gördüğüm her şey
benim normalimken
ama aslında çok anormal bir durummuş
işte normal bir şey değilmiş
Bu anormal durumla yüzleştiğinizde bu
sefer
engelleri Ondan sonra etiketlerin
bunların nasıl fırsata çevirebilirim
diye kendi kendimle oyun oynamaya
başladım dedim ki her Hayır her engel
Her göz ardı edilmiş benim Bir fırsatım
olsun negatif gözüken her ne varsa karşı
taraf adında bende ben onları nasıl
pozitife çevirebilirim
Çünkü benim
ben cinsiyetime takılan birisi olmadım
hayatım boyunca yani altı Kız zaten ilk
sivil toplumculu Ben ailede öğrendim
Kadın dayanışmasını zaten kadınların bir
arada olma kültürünü de biliyoruz
Erenköy Kız Lisesi benim cv'ndeki en
havalı Yar Ötesi olmadı benim için Çünkü
İstanbul'da ya da büyükşehirde okuyanlar
başka ülkelere giderken ben zaten başka
bir ülkeye gelmiştim İstanbul'a
gelmiştim
O yüzden benim göç Hikayem buydu okulda
seçmeler yapılıyor Ben de görünmek
istiyorum
beni de görsünler beni de alsınlar ben
de aslında kaynaşmak istiyorum Tabii o
zamanlar Şivan bu kadar şu anda güzel mi
bilmiyorum ama bu kadar güzel değildi
doğal olarak sürekli yakalanıyordum
şifremden dolayı hep açıklamak zorunda
kalıyordum Ben Aleviliği sünnili
şafiliği lisede öğrendim çünkü
bilmiyordum yani şeyi hatırladım
şafilikle deyince bizim bir Siverek'te
bir fırın sahibi vardı Biz kız çocukları
ekmek almaya gittiğimizde Elimizin onun
elinde değmesine izin vermezdi oradan
anlardım abdestlerini bozulduğunu
aradaki farkı bu kadar biliyorum ve
sürekli ne ben kimimin cevabını
bulamadım
Kürt müyüm Kürdüm
Arap mıyım Arapım Türk müyüm Türküm ben
o bölgede doğduğum büyüdüm oranın yemek
kültürü oranın evliliği oranı taziyesi
oranı türküleri Neyse ben oyum
ayrıştıramadım kendimi kabul görmek için
de hiçbir zaman dilimi değiştirmedim
ben kendimi reddederek başkaları
tarafından kabul görmek benim için çok
onurlu bir şey olmayacaktı
bir gün sokaktan eve geliyorum Babam da
arkamdan girdi Ben tabi kendi kafamda bu
duygularla savaşırken vücut dilime nasıl
yansıdığını farkında değilim
babam içeriye girdi seni sokakta gördüm
dedi
duvarın dibinden yürüyordun
[Alkış]
benim kızımsan duvarın dibinden
yürümeyeceksin dedi
Aslında Bizler bir kadının kucağında
doğuyoruz bizi onlar büyütüyor ama
babaların kız çocukları ve erkek
çocukları hayatındaki yeri çok farklı
babamın o Özgüven o cesaret verici
hareketiyle Ben hayatım boyunca kime
hizmet ettiğimi Hep sordum ruhuma hizmet
ettim ama aslında attan inip eşeğe binen
bir aile hizmet etmek istedim babamın
o Siverek'te yaşadığımız bölgedeki
kaybetti İstanbul'da kaybettiği gücün
aslında Ben peşine düşmüş çok sorguladım
kendimi Benim derdim Ne niye bu kadar
çok çalışıyorum neden yetmiyor bana
neden daha çok ben de varım deme
ihtiyacı hissediyorumun altında yatan
Aslında bu duygu
biliyorum akıllıyım Evet iyi eğitim
alamadım ama ben de varım
Hayat böyle bir şey aslında hep kendimi
tutmaya Çalışıyordum ama nedense olmuyor
çünkü o günler geliyor gözümün önüne
yani istenmeyen göçlere maruz kalan
insanları anlamak zorundasınız insanlar
isteyerek bir isteyerek geliyorsunuz bir
de istemeden koparttılarak geliyorsunuz
o bölgenin kaderi orada ne vardıysa
halen kimlik kimlerle zoru varsa halen
bitmeyen bir süreç nedense
ve üniversite sınavı
yani aldığım eğitim ortadaydı 3 yıllık
Erenköy Kız Lisesi benim geçmişteki 8
yıllığın boşluğunu dolduramadı doğal
olarak
Açıköğretim Fakültesi türkiye’de ilk
defa açılmıştı
Harika bir şey dedim ben dedim
Açıköğretim fakültesine gireyim ben de
zaten hayatım boyunca
Siverek'te bana Çocukluğumda kim sorsa
ne olmak istiyorsun ilk hostes demiştim
Hani rol modelinizden bahsediyorlar mı
Siverek'te Kim o testi yok kimse uçağa
bile bilmemiştik rol modelim Ben hostes
olacağım Sonra gazetede bir haber
çıkmıştı işte uçak düştü herkes öldü
hemen Gazeteci olmak istedim Aslında iki
meslek de o benim çocukluğumda iz
bırakmak
dünyayı kucaklamak sınırları isyan eden
Madem öleceğiz iz bırakmak zorunda
kendime farkında olmadan veren birisi
için iki meslekte Açık Öğretim de çok
örtüşüyordu
orada da sınırlar yoktu
çok da başarılı bir şekilde okudum mezun
oldum işe gireceğim
Biz kız çocuklarının yetiştirme tarzına
baktığımızda erkeklere de yapıyorlar
bunu bugün çok kadın odaklı bir
konuşmalar geçti ama ben kadının da
erkeğin de bu ülkede çok acı çektiğini
biliyorum dünyada böyle yani biz sokakta
Onlar var diye paranın iktidarın
sahibiler diye onların acı
çekmediklerini düşünemeyiz Onlar da çok
acı çekiyor Çok baskı altındalar bunu
itiraz ettikleri için sorunlar bu kadar
derinleşiyor konuşamıyorlar konuşsalar
kendileriyle başkalarıyla da
konuşacaklar Evet ben de insanım Benim
de Ruhum Var
açık öğretim mezun olduk bir bankaya
gireceğim ama hayatı bilmiyoruz İşte bu
kız çocuklarını bize yetiştirirken ne
yapıyorlar önce kolumuzu kanadımızı
kırıyorlar değil mi Sevgi adı altında
sürekli korunaklı büyüyoruz Ben bankaya
girene kadar yani üniversiteyi bitirip
bankaya girene kadar ben Erenköy'den
Avrupa yakasında tek başıma üniversite
için gidip gelmiştim ama İstiklal
caddesini bilmiyordum tarla başını hiç
bilmiyordum
bankaya girdim Açıköğretim mezun olduğum
için banka beni kapanacak olan
manuel bilgisayarı olmayan Tarlabaşı
şubesine Verdiler ben o zaman bunun
etiketimle alakalı olduğunu hiç
düşünemedim ama aslında öyleydi benden
bir şey olmazdı Ben Açıköğretim
mezunuydum onlar için de kapanacak Bir
şubeye verilmesi en doğal şeydi
başlangıçta dedim ya engelleri fırsata
çevirme hikayesi tarla başı benim hayatı
öğrendiğim yeri oldu Çok samimi
söylüyorum
farklı cinsel yönelimler hayat kadınları
onlarla kasa dairesine inerken sorduğum
sorularla o zaman ki dönüşüm
ameliyatlarına kadar her şeyi 87-90
arası öğrendim O farklı cinsel yönelimi
olan insanların toplum tarafından nasıl
dışlandığını şahit oldum genelevde
çalışan kadınların da çocukları
yuvalardaydı Düşünsenize yani o
kolumuzda kanadımızda kırarak büyüyen
Biz kız çocukları ne zaman hayatı
Öğreniyoruz işte parayı ne zaman tanıdım
bankada kariyer planı neydi orada duydum
yürüyüşleri çok farklı
gerçekten öyle erkeğin en büyük gücü
şuradan geliyor
ikincisini zaten biliyorsunuz
sonra bu müşterilerin bankaya girip
çıkarken ki o halleri acayip hoşuma
gitti
Müşterilerden çok etkilendim
Ticaret yapmalıyım şimdiki adı
girişimcilik havalı o zaman ticaret
erbapları var bir de memurlar var zaten
kız çocukları banka dışında bir yerde
çalıştırılamaz özel sektöre koyarsanız
namus elden gidebilir patron filmlerden
etkilenmişler Patron sana işte bir şey
yapabilir sürekli bize
cinsiyetimizle alakalı Yani sürekli
böyle yürümek zorundayız sonra bir gün
Müşterilerden biri banka derken şey dedi
yolda yürürken o kadar sert yürüyorsun
ki dedi
Diyemedim ki yıllarca sonunda büyüdüm
kızımı 40 Askerin içinde kısa koysam
kızı olan kız çıkar kızı olan kız nedir
her şey karışık
bir kere
Biz
erkekleri hiç tanıyamadık
erkeklerde kadınları tanımadı
farkında mısınız hep ayrı büyütüldük hep
birbirimizle tehdittik Hep erkekler bize
tehditti
Yani ben hep soruyorum bizi kimden
korumaya çalıştınız
babanıza abinize Eşinize sorduğunda hem
cinsinden bizi korumaya çalışıyor ya Hem
cinsini fark ettirsene uyandırsana
yanlışın olduğunu ona Sen anlatsana yok
Biz hep erkeklerden korktuk sonra da
biz Türk kadınları erkek Sevmeye de
Bilemedik sevgili olmayı da bilemedik
sonradan tanıştık Çünkü şimdi bu
sonradan tanışıklıkta ne kadar derin
ilişki kurabilirsiniz Zaman geçiyor Bir
de bakıyorsunuz gençlikler gitmiş olur
çocuk sezon içinde yuvarlanmışsınız
nasıl böyle konuları birbirine
bağlıyorum değil mi oradan oraya Oradan
oraya ben de şaşırıyorum Bazen tekrar
başa dönüyorum
benim müşterilerin tavır davranışlarına
etkilendim rahmetli babama gittim Dedim
ki gel sen de iş yapalım dedim ben
görüyorum dedim
nasıl dedi ya burası dedim bizim
yemeklerimizi acayip hasta salçaya
Bulgura bibere onları getirsek O zaman
işte isim de veremiyorum öyle pazarlar
yok
yok dedim ne kadar Aydın bir adam da
olsa Elalem kültürüne yenik düştüğümüz
anlarımız oluyor şu anda Bizlerde böyle
ahkam kesebiliyoruz ama yenik düştüğümüz
zamanlar oluyor önemli olan uyanabilmek
yeni düşmeyip tekrar doğrunun peşinde
koşabilmek
ama ben kendi işimi yapmak istiyorum
ölüyorum buna rağmen 3 yılda Aslında
içinizdeki hırsın tetikçiyi hiç
öldürmemek lazım 3 yılda bankada O
bilgisayar olmayan bankada
Şef oldum dış ticarette Eğitmen oldum
İngilizcem yok diye beni almıyorlardı
gittim kurslara öğreneceğim dedim
ikinci Müdür oldum ve ben ayrılıyorum
dedim Çünkü çıkış Yolumun
harika bir eş seçiminden geçeceğini fark
ettim en büyük girişimim eş seçimi
adamı kullanmadım önce Sevdik
Birbirimizi
sonra Aynı kafada mıyız dedik Çünkü ben
önümde engel istemiyorum Çünkü ben de
kimseye engel olmadığını ben herkesin
fırsatı olmak için çok çaba sarf
ediyorum herkes de benim fırsatım olsun
Alparslan'a dedim ki biz evleneceğiz
kendi işine yapmayacak mısın O da zaten
çalışıyor kendi işini yapmak istiyor
evet dedi ve biz şu gördüğünüz
temizlik sektörüne girdik Türkiye
büyüyor İstanbul gelişiyor temizlik
firmalarına çok ihtiyaç var Genelde bir
alaylılar var çok böyle bu sektörde
okumuş üniversiteliler çok az bir iki
tane firma var sonra da işte evlendik
Ben de istifa edip
bu şirketin başına geçtim çok gencim çok
temizlik yaptım bakmayın 4 sene
bir kere Mavi Yaka denilen bir kesimle
tanıştım
Kim bunlar
Evet bir göz ardı edilen bir kesim var
Türkiye'de
sektörler sınıflar tarafından
oluşturulmuş
ve biz bunları görmüyoruz Bu ülke ne
yaşlılarını görüyor ne
eğitimsizini Halbuki eğitimlilerin
onlara borcu var Sen okudun Sen
öğreteceksin Sen okudun Sen el
vereceksin
yaşlılar ve mavi yaka denilen işçi
kesimi maalesef görünmüyor herkes aynı
yaş grubunda birbirlerine bakıyor
bankada müşteriler
benimle
randevulaşıp iş yapmak adına
şey bir arada olmak isteyen adamlar
temizlikçi olduğumda
yine bir engel daha
yeni bindim hayatım hep eşeği Ata
çevirmekle geçti aslında eşek de çok iyi
koşar Bir de hep kendime şey diyordum
Ben çalışınca Allah bana veriyor
sonradan öğrendim ki olumlama diye bir
şey varmış hep yanlışım
çalışmadan da alanlar varmış ama ben
kendi kendime öyle bir şeymişim ki ben
çalışırsam Allah bana verecek çalıştığım
için veriyor kendime yüklenmişimde
yüklenmişim
girişimcilik fırsat demek değil mi
fırsatları gör oraya git
ben bu fırsatı görüp Bu sektöre girdiğim
için sonra belli bir seviyeye geldiğimde
8 senede ekonomik anlamda
olmuştum çok çalıştım verdi
Tamam çok çalıştım verdi rahat harcama
yapabiliyorum yine ruhumdaki açlık
devreye girdi
farklı yerel ve Global çok farklı
stk'larda aktif roller aldım Burada da
gençler 2004'ten beri Türkiye'deki
gençler ile bir arada olmak için çok
emek harcıyorum Çok çaba sarf ediyorum
bunun altında yatan hikayeyi de buldum
kalabalıkta Yalnızdım kalabalık bir
ailede değildim küçük olduğum için
yalnızdım
sen sus ne bilirsin küçük Çayda Kendini
büyük balıklı zannediyorsun Ata
sözlerine deyimlere bakar mısınız vur
beline kazmayı Yani sen olmamak için
elinden gelen her türlü geri bildirimler
yapılıyor o yüzden
gençler olmadan asla dedim
mutlaka Biz bir arada olmalıyız onlara
öğreten anlatan değil onlarla eş Kalpten
Kalbe yatayda Bir arada olmak zorundayız
Burada da harika eşim doğru seçmişim
temiz adam saç yok
sonrası
stk'lardan çok farklı şeyler gördüm
Türkiye değişmiyorsa
stk'lardaki hareketin kendini
sorgulaması lazım kadın istihdamı kadın
girişimci yüzdesi her şey çok yavaş Hani
bu kadar yıl bu kadar insan buralardaysa
neden bu yüzdeler oynamıyor Çünkü
orada en büyük engeli Türkiye'yi
Gezerken de kültür olduğunu gördüm
gelene görene kültür en büyük düşmanımız
kelimelerle onları empozelerle
beynimizin genetiğimize kadar
işletmişler ve biz o kadar
içselleştirmişiz ki bunları Ayıptır
Günahtır Elalem ne der ki Fatih Ürek
bunu şarkısını yapmış
derin konu ama Fatih Ürek şarkısında
zaten Elalem Ne Derse desinle işi
bitirmiş Biz o kadar kabul görme
o kadar sevgi açlığımız var ki kabul
görmek için
inanmadığımız belki Elimizi
bulaştırmayacağımız tüm yanlışın içinde
kendimizi bulaştırmış durumdayız Bu
ekrandakiler kim diyeceksiniz
2017 yılında bana bir mektup geldi
dünyada fark yaratan 50 kadından biri
seçildiniz Türkiye beni görmedi Amerika
beni gördü Daha ne olsun yani Türkiye'de
daha bana yeni yeni bir iki tane bir şey
verdiler ödül işin esprisi burada önemli
olan görünür olabilmek benim hikayemde
kadınların finanse erişim konusu hep bir
soru
paraya kolay erişemiyoruz
2012 yılında Arya kadın yatırım
platformunda ortam Ahu ile birlikte bir
yola çıkalım dedik kadınların finanse
erişim konusunda tek çözüm kadın odaklı
Bir Melek Yatırım Platformu olalım o
yıldan beri kadınlar için
finanse erişim açısından çok kadın
şirkette desteklendi
yatırımcılarla buluşturduk bu yılın
sonunda da bir Bankayla birlikte ortak
bir fon kurduk şimdi eşitlikçi
şirketlere Yatırım yapılacak
yatırımcılarla bir araya getireceğiz
sıkılmadınız değil mi
oradan bana bakıyorlar bitti diye
teşekkür ederim
Tamam dedim bu kadar çok şey yapıyoruz
sorunlar ne
erkeklik bir sorundu bu ülkede Kadın
olmak da bir sorundu erkekli için
erkekler konuşuyor ama bu defa farklı
konuşuyor diye bir proje yazdım 2018'den
beri faaliyette erkeklerin kendilerine
yapılan
baskılardan
nasıl isyan etmediklerini başlarına
gelenleri anlamaları için öyle değil mi
Amcacığım Çok baskı görmedin mi Hayır
sonra Sakalımız yok ama sözümüz para
eder
yine biz kadınların en çok kullandığı
karşı tarafı onurlandırırken kendimize
nasıl konumlandırdığımızı fark
etmediğimiz bir söze yönelik de bir
proje yazdık sözünü eyleme dönüştüren
kadınlar Mavi Yaka hikayeleri iki
yakamızı bir araya getirdik
sınıfsal eşitsizliğe karşı
aklım çalıştıkça sorunları gördükçe
kimse elini bulaştırmadı her ne varsa
bulaştırmaya
Çünkü
Birilerinin bir deli bir taş atar kırk
akıllı çıkaramaz derler ya
gücüm yettiğince bunlara yönelik
projeler yapmaya devam edeceğim gençler
ile yapıyorum zaten benim sosyal medya
hesaplarımda deli olmak özgürlüktür
Akıllısı çok olan bir ülkenin Delilere
de ihtiyacı vardır deli olmaktan da
acayip gurur duyuyorum Çünkü kendimi
hiçbir sınırın içine koymadım
ve geldik sonra
[Alkış]
babamın ölüm yıldönümü 26 Nisan babama
bir Instagram'da bir mektup yazmak
geldiği içinden öyle artistlik şeyleri
bilmem ama içimden geliyorsa iyi
kullanırım kelimeleri
dedim ki babacığım 16 yıl geçti her şey
bıraktığın gibi
hala insanlar ne aradığını bilmiyor
hızır'dan Medet Uman bir dünyaya döndü
Burası ama bir tek şey var Artık senin o
duvar dibinden yürüyen kızın artık Yolun
tam ortasında